let's go next to lahav from greensboro
lahav welcome
hello can you hear me yes i can
okay um i'd like to ask about um the
system of government that we have in the
united states because
in my opinion uh you know like
multi-party parliamentary systems like
in germany or denmark
yes and other countries well i think
that's a pr preferable system because
mostly because of the multi-party aspect
i mean i have issues with the two-party
duopoly i'm curious just
what do you think of the idea of a
multi-party parliamentary system could
it work here
well whether it could work i mean i
think the answer is it depends how hard
we want to try i think it of course it
could work
i tend to like the multi-party
parliamentary system you often hear as a
stated downside of such a system that it
makes it too easy for extremists to get
representation so imagine that
uh you know five percent of the vote
goes to
the kkk party and that means that they
would get 21 or some number of seats in
the house of representatives or
something like that but i think there's
safeguards against that and i don't
think it's as big a risk maybe as as
some people believe it to me i also see
it as a way of you know we talk all the
time
how can we break the duopoly
and often we say well you got to get rid
of the electoral college and then you
got to do ranked choice voting and fix
campaign finance you know all these
different things a multi-party
parliamentary system at least at the
house of representatives level might be
a shortcut to breaking the two-party
duopoly so i'm very positive for a
number of reasons on it i don't i'm not
as knowledgeable about it as someone who
maybe lives in such a system so there
may be downsides i'm not considering
well one downside
like israel is the biggest downside i
can think of because what they have is
each country has a cut off
for how for what percentage of the vote
you have to get to receive seats in
israel it is way too low you get like 20
parties in government in an endless
cycle of elections it's a complete mess
right other countries like germany have
a higher cutoff now another issue i
actually support abolishing the senate
like
it's not democratic in its current form
i don't even see a better form of it
and if there was a parliamentary system
i don't see the point of a senate
oh i have ranted and raved about the
undemocratic nature of the senate
i forget the exact numbers but i think
it's something like
the senators representing 17 of the u.s
population can form a majority because
of how undemocratic it is
and um i i like you
when i think about how you fix the
senate you're basically making it the
house so do you yeah it's
the senate is a mess i'm with you
and final question this one is slightly
unrelated but i always get annoyed with
the media when they pretend
that both sides are equal and this is
just another partisan fight
and it's really not so how do you get
that sort of i'll call it the both sides
culture
out of the media particularly corporate
media you just have to repeat over and
over again
this is not a both sides thing so when
when corporate media has one person that
understands and accepts the science of
climate change and another person who
denies it and then you go well
both sides you guys kind of debate and
see who convinces who
one side is not based in reality and so
that's just a matter of i think if if
you if one is a guest in such a
situation you have to repeat that
there's a false neutrality that being
created here that's deceptive but you've
just got to keep repeating it over and
over again there's no other way
well from their perspective if
someone a climate denier is going to go
on to cnn and yeah then the host will
announce that they're a liar they're
probably not going to actually go on so
it might be a discreet way to stop these
people from actually showing up on cable
news yeah i can't think of what it is
but maybe you're right maybe there is a
way
okay thank you for taking my call my
pleasure there is lahav from greensboro
and that is going to do it for calls
today we will take calls again
and i look forward to speaking to many
more of you next time